Well.
Another major consideration and the evolution of pathogen very lens is host
range or how many different hosts that pathogen can infect.
There is also the issue of spillover virulence that happens with what we call
facultative opportunists.
That is a case where the virulence is not been evolutionarily adjusted to the
human population for example.
And then another issue is that of imperfect vaccines and the evolution of
virulence.
So first is is the pathogen infecting one or is it infecting many host species?
The principle here is that a jack of all trades,
the master of none,
the more host species that are regularly infected,
the less well adapted the pathogen will be to any one of them.
The pathogen that evolves to be good at exploiting one host loses efficacy in
the other hosts and that is how attenuated live vaccines in fact are produced.
Okay.
Serial passage,
which is the process used in making attenuated live vaccines is actually an
evolutionary technology.
Microbiologists use serial passage to study pathogen virulence and they also use
it to produce live attenuated vaccines.
It works because pathogens evolve rapidly to specialize on new hosts.
When that is the only option that they are given.
The experimental host is therefore chosen to be genetically uniform and it is
not allowed to co evolve.
The results of these processes demonstrate widespread trade offs and performance
on different hosts and these trade offs in nature limit host ranges and
constrain the emergence of new diseases.
So this is what a serial transfer experiment might look like.
You have a group of genetically homogeneous mice,
which you've never seen this particular pathogen before.
One of them is infected,
the parasite grows exponentially and is then extracted.
It is then used to infect the next host.
This process continues each time the parasite is encountering a naive host that
is genetically uniform and growing exponentially.
So essentially from the parasites point of view,
a serial transfer experiment is exposure to a unlimited environment that is not
changing and therefore to which you can adapt very precisely.
Yeah.
The pathogens are growing exponentially all the time because the interval
between infections is kept fairly short and they're always going into
immunologically naive hosts.
So in essence,
life is simple and good.
They're very lens on the new host.
Then increases and they're very once on their original hosts.
For the one that they came from that's not involved in this process decreases.
Here's an example.
Here's cell Salmonella typhimurium.
It's a bacterium is being passaged in mice and here are the number of mice that
the percentage of mice,
not not the number,
the percentage of mice that die when infected after passages going two,
four,
six,
eight,
10 so 10 passages was enough to get salmonella.
Very good at killing noise.
Here is what went on with the ability of polio virus to kill monkeys where it is
being passaged in cell culture.
Okay,
so cell culture is genetically uniform.
The monkey is the test host.
The longer it's passaged in cell culture,
the less able it is to kill monkeys.
After 50 passages,
it was judged to be attenuated and safe for use and that in fact is how the CBN
life polio vaccine was originally produced.
These are the data from the production of that vaccine.
Another interesting piece of virulence biology has to do with spillovers and a
spillover occurs when a pathogen which is in a natural reservoir and is well
adapted to its natural host encounters.
A new host and spills over into it,
and the issue is what is then?
It's very,
once it is in that new host,
a facultative opportunist.
An example is Ebola.
Some of the most virulent human diseases are caused by pathogens that actually
spend most of their time in other hosts.
Their impact on humans is mostly irrelevant to their evolution in their natural
hosts,
which are often bats or rodents.
Many of them kill humans too rapidly to transmit effectively and other zone
audit confections have little impact in pass unnoticed.
In fact,
we probably are infected many,
many more times than we know.
Let's take a look at an ecological way of classifying pathogens.
Some are obligate parasites and there are specialists on humans,
for example,
that would be plasmodium falciparum,
HIV flu,
TB.
There are non specialists such as Lyme disease,
Borrelia Burgdorferi,
Ui,
the rabies virus,
Salmonella Bartonella.
Okay.
There are also facultative parasites,
things that can be free living or parasitic.
The specialists on humans are commensal opportunists such as staff and
Enterococcus,
Faecalis,
hemophilus,
influenzae and strip.
And then there are non specialists that are facultative and some of these are
environmental opportunists.
For example,
pseudomonas Aeruginosa,
Burke hold area also wrote a caucus and mycobacterium marina.
So a principle here is that a response to a source as much stronger than a
response to a sink.
So an obligate parasite is living in a source and respond strongly to it.
Where as a facultative parasite might experience a human host as a sink.
In other words,
it is not a place where it is going to reproduce well or perhaps disperse well
from an over evolutionary time.
That means that its interactions with the human are not going to be as finely
honed as it would would be with an obligate parasite.
Yeah,
so there were really two principles of pathogen adaptation in Nevada rotation in
general.
One is that the significance of effects depends on how frequently a condition is
encountered.
And the other is the one I've just mentioned,
which is the responses to sources are then much stronger than responses to
sinks.
So there's an analogy here to the evolution of aging.
Genes are transmitted more by the young than by the old pathogens adapt more to
the things that they encounter frequently in and are accustomed to living in
then to the things that they spill over into and experiences sinks.
Another issue with variance in a very important one is raised by imperfect
vaccines.
Yeah.
Vaccines are a major human intervention in pathogen evolution.
They are one of the biggest,
most challenging new developments that pathogens have ever seen.
Childhood vaccines,
which are a major component of the reduction in infant mortality over the last
hundred years.
Our sterilizing and they protect nearly perfectly once vaccinated and once a
response to vaccination is produced,
then the person vaccinated is going to be disease resistant probably for the
entire life.
Boosters are needed in some cases,
but most of these protect nearly perfectly
imperfect vaccines are different.
They are a threat because they allow transmission.
Not everyone who is vaccinated clears the pathogen from their system and can
therefore,
in some cases transmitted to another person.
The cause increased very variance for two reasons.
First,
the extent host survival time that allows more virulent strains to transmit.
And second,
by reducing the cost of various islands,
they shift the balance in the virulence transmission tradeoff.
So by reducing the cost of virulence,
what we mean is that the vaccine is allowing strains to survive and continue to
transmit.
Did in an unvaccinated person would have killed that person too quickly.
Yeah.
Unvaccinated hosts in this scenario will then experience a nastier disease once
the pathogen has evolved in response to a vaccine campaign with an imperfect
vaccine.
Now,
that doesn't mean we shouldn't vaccinate.
It is still wise to vaccinate because even an imperfect vaccine will save
millions of lives.
However,
it is useful to know about in the plan for the evolutionary consequences of
imperfect backseats.
We need contingency plans,
contingency contingency plans for increased variance if imperfect vaccines are
used.
So to summarize,
when pathogens are forced to specialize on a new single host,
their very once in that host increases and they're very balanced in their old
host decreases.
That's the evolutionary basis for producing attenuated live vaccines.
Spillover events can have any very Ellen's level at all,
higher,
low.
Some are extremely,
very Olin because the pathogens are not yet adapted to humans.
That is the case with Ebola,
Mers,
SARS,
rabies,
things like that.
Imperfect vaccines can drive the evolution of increased variance and where we
are going to need contingency plans for them.